very good let's make a start on on this
session which is about it was going to
be entitled the vision for data science
education I've actually metamorphosize
did a little bit into our vision at
Wolfram in terms of global education
revolt reform sort of vision progress
and plans and I want to cover slightly
wider swath of discussion than I was
planning to cover a little bit well I
guess when I made up the title so let's
start by saying something that has
become more evident to me over the last
few years which is that Wolfram in some
form is kind of at the center of STEM
education from every angle and you know
it's kind of like you start to think
well there must be lots of people in the
world who can do this thing or that
thing in STEM education and in many
cases you come down to the thing that
actually there are very few and that
we're kind of at the center of it and if
we don't do something then nobody will
and so we've kind of come this
realization there are a whole collection
of things that we're very much in the
center of and that we need to pick
carefully what to do but basically that
that's a you know an important position
we have which we want to exercise well
for everyone and so what do we mean by
this well I think we've got great
technology which allows educational
things to be built very well and I think
we've also got two strategies around the
curriculum and I want to separate those
two ah you know so we need to kind of
you know there's there's a problem with
particularly math curricula and there's
a new emerging coding curricula and
those to underlie most of what's in STEM
education in terms of math and coding
and being able to put things technically
and we kind of have the best support for
leading replacement for that in terms of
technology and so really what I want to
talk about in this I think there are
sort of various topics one can cover
there
coding there's assessment there's modern
delivery of traditional maths and of new
mass and then there's computer-based
maths which is the direction i pioneered
in trying to fundamentally change the
curriculum so the way to think about
this is it's kind of like there are you
know there are kind of two directions
really one is how do we best use our
technology to do the best we can with
traditional curricula and then there's
the longer medium to longer term vision
of how do we switch to push the right
curriculum around the world which I
don't think is what we've got and I want
to spend a good fraction this talk
talking through why I don't think we've
got that right curriculum and what we
can do to fix it some of you may have
heard some of this before terms of
computer-based maths but i'm hoping also
to give some update on where we've got
to with that initiative so but let me
set down the the sort of argument for
why we need a fundamentally transformed
curriculum well the good news if you're
interested in math or maths is that math
is now high on the agenda in most
developed and even in developing
countries so if you look back 20 years
political agendas have less about math
in them and so in a sense that's fair
amount of pressure building on how do we
improve education for math um the bad
news about it is that most of what's
being discussed in my view is about 80%
the wrong subject so it's like there's
this thing called math that's being
discussed and being discussed a lot and
people think it's very important to do
something about math but they also are
discussing or they're vague or muddled
or it's confused what exactly they are
discussing and eighty percent of it
seems pretty much wrong and so what's
wrong about this so I think there are
two subjects named the same thing the
one in the outside world that most of
you are very involved in is this subject
where most of the time we're abstracting
problems and setting up problems and
getting computers to calculate the
results most of the time in education
we are spending getting students to
learn how to calculate results
themselves and not use a computer so
there's the fundamental difference
eighty percent of the time in education
is used learning how to hand calculate
whereas almost all the time in the
outside world is learnt or is used with
mathematics trying to use the
mathematics with whatever is the best
machinery actually to calculate the
result so we fundamentally have a
problem of you know there are two maths
going on and they're discrepant and
until that bridge that chasm is bridged
we aren't going to have success in math
education so in order to understand
what's really going on there let's ask a
few questions let's zoom sort of back
out then ask a few questions why is
everyone in the world supposed to learn
maths right there are very few subjects
in this category I mean your own
language is a subject usually in that
category history perhaps is a subject
that category but many other subjects
have far less presence in curricula than
maths why is that well I think there are
three good reasons to learn the right
subject of maths first is technical jobs
that have driven and are continuing to
drive our economic development secondly
it's what i would call everyday living
just to survive and know what's going on
in the world you've got to be much more
quantitative and you were even 15 20 30
years ago and thirdly it's what I might
call logical mind training thinking
about you know ways to analyze things in
life they may be explicitly mathematical
things or they may not be you know how
do you think about business problems how
do you think about you know solving
social problems it's very good to have a
logical structure to think about these
things and maths has been an incredibly
powerful system of problem-solving
through the ages and knowing how that
system works and being able to apply in
different circumstances seems extremely
useful so those are three reasons why
the right subject of maths seems to me
justifiable for a broad swath of our
societies what is maths well I think
it's a four
step process of problem-solving so step
one you defining questions if I talk for
too long in this room we seal the room
and we stop the air conditioning so
there's no air going in and out how long
can we all survive okay that's a
question and we are turning we're
defining that question in a sense the
next step is you want to translate that
question to math why do you bother to do
this why don't we just discuss the
question in English well because math is
very precise and if you abstract it to
math people for hundreds of years have
worked out that if you take a whole
series of problems that sound different
in English they can actually be the same
basic problem in math let's say they're
an equation and you need to solve the
equation so abstraction step two is
absolutely critical step 3 you're taking
that question and turning it into an
answer still in the abstract form so
question 3 is step three you are
essentially computing and step four is
you're taking that answer an abstract
form and you're turning it back to
answer the question in words how long
can we survive if the answer comes out
as minus 19 we probably got something
wrong and we have to go round it again
and figure out we got wrong so you know
if minus 19 hours was how long we could
survive there's a problem in the
calculation but one way or another
you've got to go through that sort of
problem solving process and the problem
right now is pretty simple to describe
we're spending almost all our time in
education doing step 3 by hand and
that's drowning out these other steps
and it's almost you know it's actually
taking away effort from these others and
most of the other rest of the time in
real life you're doing steps one two and
four so we should be using computers
primarily to do step 3 and we should be
using students primarily to do steps one
two and four and I mean just to be clear
about this right now in most maths
education you know the teacher defines
the book or the teacher or the
curriculum defines the question the
teacher then tells the option does the
translation to maths so you know here's
the quadratic equation you go off and
solve it but that's what you're normally
given the student computes the answer
and then usually made it as a little bit
of interpretation at the end but it
doesn't usually tie back to any question
because they don't know what the
original question was anyway now I mean
this is a process that just to be clear
you need to go through several times
sometimes you know you need to go
through defining translating question
eventually after several rounds of this
process you sometimes you get to your
result so math in my view is a much
broader subject than calculating and by
the way while we're about its stem is
obviously by definition it broader
subject the math pure mathematician
sometimes try and claim that math is the
calculating but you got to be very
careful if you're a pure mathematician
claiming now because you're claiming
that then I think you end up if you work
through the logic correctly in claiming
that math is a very side subject and
it's sort of important to understand the
difference so let me just give you a
very simple example I often give here
this is an example that many people have
to do in school you know how can you
solve a set of linear simultaneous
equations but it's very odd if you stick
a cube in here and you get an answer
like that right they don't usually do
that in school but it's the same thing
conceptually it's the same thing you
know the fact is my problem may have
ended up with an equation with a Cuban
it or it may have ended up with a linear
equation who cares why are we limiting
people only two things that happen to
have nice calculating that seems nuts
and in fact it even gets worse than that
right because as you know i can go and
talk to my iphone if it sir I'm not sure
it's on the network let me try this
solve x cubed plus two equals to y and y
minus x equals 5 and sort of siri
willing we may be able to not so good i
think i'm out of network here but anyway
you guys know the know what's going on
here um c x minus oh i see what's
happened here um well anyway I for some
reason Siri seems tough
Kate cut out but anyway I mean the point
is you know I can talk to my phone as
you know in 20 seconds usually it's on
the network and I can do the same thing
and get the answer and you've got to ask
you know if I can talk to my phone in 20
seconds and get it to solve a problem
that most people after 12 years of math
education can't solve why the hell are
we teaching them that why is that what
we're focused on it seems absolutely
nuts it doesn't seem to do anyone much
good so what are the other problems with
current curricula is that they're what I
call mechanics centered so they're
worrying about what's inside first you
know can you invert a matrix can you
simplify surd's can you use the chain
rule what I think curricular ought to be
focused on is problems what's the actual
problem you're trying to solve you know
design a currency what kinds notes do
you need you know make a perfect
password for your login right it's a
problem of any six or seven-year-old how
do I stop my friends breaking into my
computer if it seems like a modern
problem it's not that's you know what's
a beautiful shape that's a perfectly
valid question I mean the Greeks thought
about that it's a perfectly valid
question it's fuzzy much of matts many
am asked questions are fuzzy half the
difficulties in taking the fuzzy
question and turning it into the
abstract question you can actually use
math to help and part of a problem if
normally if you try and do that is that
you can't do that if you're limited to
only linear equations because the the
problems just didn't end up as linear
equations so your math is then useless
so one of the things I believe strongly
is I mean I wrote this little sort of
summary of the logic that I have if you
believe math is for all students that
kind of implies that math and education
needs to be approximately identical to
math in the real world because otherwise
I don't see how you can justify it for
real for student I mean why should
everyone be learning this if that most
people have no use for it right and that
implies that math in education should be
something like computer-based maps which
is what I'm talking about now if you
take the corollary of that you know it
doesn't it
so you know one of the problems right
now I think is that math is a kind of a
proxy for math in education most people
who disagree with this position do agree
with me about one thing they say yes
you're right about how real math is in
the real world you're right computers do
most the calculating the thing is we
think we should be teaching something
totally different to people in education
so I say well hang on just a number but
why do you start from the idea of a
proxy I mean you're agreeing with me
it's a proxy but why do you think it's
better to teach people something
different to start with now maybe they
have a good argument for that but
they've got to first admit that what
they're teaching is not the main subject
the main subject in the real world is to
scrap them from that and it's actually
one of the ways i sometimes summarize
this is to say you know current maths is
a bit like ancient Greek right I mean I
learn to ancient Greek at school and
it's a very fine specialist subject and
if you enjoy ancient Greek it's a great
thing to learn but I wouldn't force the
entire world's population to learn
ancient Greek for 12 years of their life
it just doesn't seem something you can
justify now another thing that's
entering about proxies is Latin I don't
know which of your countries Latin was
taught and is still taught as a
general-purpose subject but years ago
certainly in Britain Latin was a pretty
general purpose subject it was clearly a
proxy for something even in Britain
people didn't go around talking Latin to
each other so the question is why were
they learning Latin well I think the
reason was probably one of the reasons
was to teach them English grammar one of
the amusing things we used to have in
our European office is that if we wanted
to know about English grammar and we had
anybody from outside England there we
would go and ask them about the English
grammar because nobody in England had
actually learned English grammar we
weren't taught it we were taught if
you're lucky and you go to a fancy
school you were taught Latin otherwise
you've kind of learned nothing about
English grammar right so maybe Latin is
a good proxy for english grammar I think
there's some justification is actually
not a bad proxy for english grammar but
let's be honest about what it's for math
seems an awfully poor proxy educational
maths for the real maths right now it
doesn't seem to be infusing people as
little justification for much of it it's
really hard to justify so I think but
let's be let's be clear if we do believe
it's a proxy why we're doing it now how
does math and coding relate I think math
as a system for doing stem and life it's
a problem solving system and I think
coding is a way you express math the
question is if you're going to write
down some abstraction how do you write
it down you could write it down in math
notation but that's very limiting you
can't right processes down you can track
algorithms down very well that in the
modern world in the sense that the
modern notation is code I know you could
argue the other way around you could
argue that math notation was one of the
first coding languages but a rather
incomplete one but one way or another
you've got to write stuff down so I
actually do think coding is a very
central part of math education and
insofar as governments are understanding
the need to teach coding I think that
they actually have not understood how
important it is and have understood it
slightly wrong because it's great and
Wolfram language because stuff is quite
literate and you can you can do things
well now here's the key thing that I
think it's worth understanding and
people that this is a fascinating thing
to me and how political decisions get
made sometimes but if you ask a
politician so why do you think maths is
very important they'll tell you because
it's it's important in many subjects and
many areas of life you know and our
economy and everything else right so yup
I agree with you there I'm the thing the
thing then is you you find out well so
what happened a hundred years ago mass
was much less on the agenda then why
well because it didn't work very well
the reality is math worked well for
things like physics you know planets as
I mentioned this morning it didn't work
well for a huge range of other things
for which we now take maths for granted
why didn't it work well it didn't work
well because we didn't have mechanized
computation there are a bunch of areas
of maths that simply only work with
mechanized kareena most the areas of
biology anything to do with large data
you know images all of these things are
purely to do with mechanized computation
being able to do the amount
calculation you need so most of the
areas in which politicians believe math
should be being applied and drive our
economy are areas that cannot exist
without mechanized computation and
didn't so therefore if you remove the
computer from math education you are
removing most of the context you can't
do the biological problems you can't do
the data science problems you can't do
the image processing you simply can't do
any of these things because they can't
be done without mechanized computation
so therefore what you're doing is you're
stripping most of the context that you
actually need for real math out of the
math curriculum this is kind of crazy
but most and the thing that you're not
stripping out this is the other thing is
you're not stripping out conceptual
understanding the fact is in the outside
world it's hard as you all know to apply
math and get good really important
results out of it so therefore what
you're not stripping out if you do it
right is the thinking you need humans to
think more for this kind of math in the
real world than you do to manage to know
the formula for solving a quadratic
equation so those are things which get
very muddled up in discussion about this
so you know it's important when you're
thinking about these things to think
about how you can reorder things in the
curriculum and why don't we teach
thermodynamics in primary school I mean
there's a lot you can understand by
looking at the math of what's happening
and just going through analyzing these
things and you know you conceal their
transitionary effects that's kind of
cool what happens when you make the Box
smaller and the temperature higher etc
etc etc and so there are lots of things
you can do if you don't have to
explicitly now do the calculations
here's an example I up to show and in
this example what we did was to split
classes up in in you know in two and we
told half the class I want you to toss a
coin and to write down heads or tails
with the actual results then the other
half we want we're going to let you just
type stuff into the computer essentially
to cheat okay and what we're then going
to do is feed both sets of results into
the computer and see if the teacher can
who's cheated well it's pretty
interesting so I've just typed these in
and if we look at the results you'll see
that actually I only passed one of the
five tests we can pretty definitively
say I was cheating but if indeed I
tossed the coin and in fact I'm gonna
cheat I'm going to semi cheat because
i'm going to do random integer let's say
on one and i'm going to do it to see
what we need 200 times so I'm going to
take so I'm sort of going to use I'm
going to semi cheat by using mathematica
is a random number generator and that's
that's copy those in the ones and zeroes
instead of heads and tails but I think
it'll still manage it and if we look at
the results it passed all five tests
that's amazing we can use data analysis
to figure out whether some of these
cheating actually that's what people do
with credit card detection and more
sophisticated way you know have you
somebody misusing or credit card so
that's a real insight there right there
which you could never do without
mechanized calculation in any serious
way that's real math in action but used
in education so one thing I want to be
clear about there are two ways to I mean
the two sets of ways in which you can
think of applying computers in education
and they are different in discrepant and
one kind of needs to understand the
difference one is computer based when is
computer-assisted so what I mean by
computer assisted is use the computer to
improve the pedagogy of learning now
there's clearly lots that can be done
right i mean the idea of a teacher
standing in front of a classroom you
know talking with a chalkboard clearly
could be improved in many many many ways
and is out of date in all sorts of ways
um but that's true of every subject you
know whether the history or english or
you know or maths clearly their
improvements in the system of pedagogy
computer-based by which i mean take the
subject in the real world and turn it
into an educational subject
computer-based maths is about the fact
that math changed as a real subject the
object changed not just the way you
teach it the subject and so when we
discuss this when I'm talking about
computer-based mats I mean take the
subject change and move it into
education obviously in order to deploy
that well you need some computer
assistance to actually make that work it
doesn't make much sense having chalk on
a chalkboard if you're discussing a
computer mechanizing computations okay
so that's the vision let me talk a
little bit about the elements of making
this change first thing we got to do is
the vision for the right subject and
this is tough I've been going on this
hard for five years and you know it is
slowly getting through in various places
that may be the subject of maths is
actually not quite the right subject and
we need to rethink it there isn't this
god-given subject called maths that
never changes the next thing which is
difficult is to build the right subject
what do you actually want to build and
what bits of maths are we talking about
so you know one of the things to do is
to try and define outcomes it's a fairly
shocking discovery of that least I
believe I've made that going around the
world to try and find a list of outcomes
of what people want from the 12 years of
mass you come up with really some pretty
lame stuff I mean as in people say we
want critical thinking well sure but
what does it mean and at the other level
you're most of these curricula say now
it's very important that people know how
to put ticks on bar charts and it's like
well maybe but it seems like there's a
level in the middle of those two which
is sort of missed so we've been trying
to work out what the outcome should be
from math education and we have this
sort of 10 dimensional list then there's
some pretty interesting steps and you
know some of it is about the actual
concepts inside an area like statistics
you know ability to describe the concept
interpreting the measures and
computational results and so forth some
of its about you know actually running
the process you know can you plan and
run a problem solving process with maths
can you actually get to an answer do you
know the management of that
that's an important part of using math
so there are many sort of dimensions to
this which one needs to think about you
know which bits of maths how do you
build the narrative around this so
another thing of making a change is to
align assessment we have not done that
much work on this yet and I think this
is an area that needs a lot more effort
it's pretty clear that in most parts of
the world people teach maths to
assessment and the assessments are kind
of goofy in most places you know can you
do this long division by hand that's not
really testing and they some of them
claimed to be problem solving some of
the better ones claimed to be problem
song but the problem then is if you're
limited to doing problem solving by hand
there are many problems you can solve
and they're not the problems you meet in
the real world if you end up with a
million data points and the question is
how do you analyze those million data
points you know in the end that's a
completely different question in
practice two here are five data points
now plot them on a graph and fit a line
through them right that's just a
different set of problems and if you
test people on how they can draw a graph
with five data points you aren't testing
than what they actually need to do with
a million data points so there's a
there's a problem of a lining assessment
and I think over time you know this will
change but that's kind of a slow process
in most places and i think one place to
start that is where adults are concerned
because adults are you know not
regulated by as much by governments and
so therefore you can actually make
changes where people want to get their
own and their own qualifications so
another thing is fixing what I call math
marketing right math marketing around
the world from education is pretty
terrible and it's a mixture of confusion
by most men most politicians in the
world who run this stuff are
non-technical so they didn't really like
math themselves they didn't really
understand it and now then in a
situation of trying to tell everyone
it's good for them she doesn't work too
well I mean an example from England I
was like you know is where they insisted
long division was a very important thing
for everyone in primary school to know
now whether or not you agree with that
and I certainly don't particularly in
that case
but it's terrible marketing it's like
you're telling people who go through
primary school the most exciting thing
that the government's decided to
highlight about primary maths is that
you can do long division this doesn't
seem like a great recipe for in
confusing people and it's even worse it
they do it because they think that some
some parents will be very excited about
forcing their kids to learn this and
maybe there are some parents who want to
you know get out a whip and whip them
into doing long division but i think the
number in most places is actually rather
small compared to the number who just
like their kids to know how to function
well in the in the real world so there's
a real problem with sort of math
marketing and i think part of that is
presenting exciting things you can do
with math things that are fun like
cheating and playing games and you know
making sure you can outdo your parents
and things like this and I think these
are all sort of important thing so we've
been trying to improve the way in which
we present some of the issues around
maths and I don't we totally succeeded
with that but I think we've got some
sort of message I'm around so another
problem in making a change like this is
you've got to mesh with today's
educational environment um you've got to
train teachers you've got to get
expectations and skills and delivery
right and confidence confidence is
really important you've also got to get
technology that works and you've got to
set up schools and so forth that's the
reality one of the problems in these
discussions is that people get so
obsessed with the reality of what they
have to do next term or next year but
they completely forget the vision the
vision just sort of flies out of the
space and so you end up with a zero
vision process and in fact I wrote a
blog post about evidence and the role of
evidence last week on my personal site
because i realize that often when you
talk about evidence led education reform
what it means is i mean it doesn't mean
randomized control trials i mean the
good thing i think in using evidence is
make you know gasps you guess what you
want to do you build the thing you then
test it and you don't see whether it
seems to work better against criteria
what happens with drugs what evidence
that
education has typically meant is you're
not allowed to build anything unless you
can prove that it fits with educational
evidence from the past right that is not
the way innovation can ever happen in
any serious way incremental it can
happen but no big innovation can ever
happen if that's what you believe has to
happen first then indeed it doesn't work
anywhere any innovation around the world
and anything outside education are in
won't work if you assume education
always has to be led by the evidence of
what's happened in the past and there's
a great Fineman the physicist Fineman
has a very nice bit when he's explaining
how science works which I quote in that
blog post which is kind of nice so
what's our progress well we found a
computer-based maths a number of years
ago for this and I think we are seeing
in some countries the discourse changing
you know there is a star to people
questioning subject we started building
a curriculum and we're making some quite
good progress with that and I think
we've built a whole bunch of frameworks
around that as to you know how do you
think through what should be in a new
curriculum how do you think through
what's real and what isn't real what all
the things should go in we haven't
succeeded everywhere there but I think
we have succeed a long way I mean the
thing I would say and a lot of those are
things like activities chapters topics
modules and modalities or the sort of
framework elements that build up
computer-based mass modules are in a
sense the set of problems that people
want to solve and these the ways that
they get solved our first major place is
Estonia where we have implemented a
pilot probability and statistics creek
and I'm pleased to say the group from
Estonia is here which is great has been
working very much on this and I'm sure
we'll be happy to talk to anyone else
from other countries who has have
questions about it we've also made an
early start in Sweden and Africa on
changing some of these things and
there's interest from many other
countries around the world it's slow
going to get these things to happen
because governments and things move
slowly things in education in general
move very slowly but i think we are we
are making very good progress and some
of the technology this conference will
improve that quite a lot so what do we
have to do well we've got to do the rest
of the math curriculum I think math one
way to think about maths I mean there
are various ways to categorize it I
think there are sort of five categories
we need to hit there's data science
probability and statistics and data
science there is geometry which i think
is a modern area there's modeling
there's what i would call architecture
of math which is kind of the underlying
structures that you need to know and
there's a fifth one that i have lost for
the moment but it's there somewhere
it'll come back to me in a second anyway
there are five our image processing
signal processing was the one I was
looking for and so these are sort of
major modern areas of math maybe there's
some others that you can suggest as well
and I think that's sort of part of what
I reckon we've probably built fifteen
percent or so of a curriculum but
probably we've done twenty-five percent
of the work in some ways at least to get
that going but you know there's a lot
more work to do in a lot more sets of
things to set up another thing to do is
we need to consumer eyes so what I mean
by that is we need to set things up so
that you don't need to have trained
teachers for many many hours to be able
to deploy this you can have students to
a certain amount of it by themselves you
can have you know home schoolers in the
u.s. do this etc etc that's an important
part of trying to get changed to happen
from the ground up and of course
assessment there's also coding education
now a lot has started up on this quite
nothing to do with us but I still think
it suffers in many ways from from the
problem that if you're already
interested in coding it's helpful if
you're not interested in coding it
hasn't quite hit the mark yet but the
fact that coding is being discussed a
lot around the world is really useful I
think to driving this and we have
started with our own idea of how to do
this with programming lab you know I
don't think this is a fully fledged
concept but i think is a way to ease
people into learning the idea of of
coding and particularly with Wolfram
language
so I want to switch gear for a moment
and just say so I've been talking about
computer-based maths and fundamentally
changing the subject in the curriculum
um it's okay i said i would overrun by
about 15 minutes so that's that was that
that was the plan the UM the um okay so
so the supporting the current math
curriculum you know we have many new
technologies that can do well with the
curriculum you're currently got and
there's no reason not to use those just
because we haven't got a completely
revised curriculum doesn't mean we
shouldn't use the technology we've got I
think these are lots of things how to
present things product ization of of
what we've got MOOCs but MOOCs which
actually do things you know where you've
got CBR CDF's and so forth problem
generators there are many many things
you can do that the one of the things
that I said the beginning is I think
we're in a sort of a unique position and
we kind of been 25 plus years as the
math company and the question is how do
we best leverage that position to move
forward it's kind of interesting to look
back 25 plus years to the launch of
Mathematica because I found this quote
from Steve Jobs at the launch of
Mathematica which in a very Steve Jobs
way as a rather clean vision which isn't
too far away from this no mathematical
revolution as the teaching and learning
of math by focusing on the pros of
mathematics without getting lost in the
grammar so in a rather different slice
but similar way I think that is what we
have the opportunity to do and then
another interesting way jobs kind of saw
that back in eighty-eight what some what
do we you know what is maths go and look
in 25 years I think people to do a
revised curriculum will see the benefits
just like universal education gave the
first countries like the UK very great
benefits from doing it first doesn't
mean the universal education everywhere
else isn't good but it kind of helped
the
okay in other places that did it early
to industrialize well and to know
basically you know to have a greater
swetha there avarom communities be able
to do high-level things and I think this
is in microcosm the same kind of change
if people can do high-level
problem-solving with math and with
coding they can go much further why now
well we talked about impetus I think
there's ubiquity of devices we've talked
about and also the interface is much
better in practice it's much easier to
do this than it was so we need to stand
on the power of automation and now is
the time to do that for stem you know
you always have a choice in education
what do you do when the world gets
automated gets mechanized what you do
one thing you can do is you can pretend
that actually it never happened and you
can teach people how to pretend to be
machines but in the end that always
loses you can teach people you know by
hand how to sow seeds in the ground but
actually if they're trying to run
agriculture that's probably not the most
useful thing for them to know and so
you've got to stand on the power of the
automation that will take you further
and now we've got that opportunity for
stem so summary let's change the world's
math curriculum over time I think it'll
take about 20 20 25 years I think we're
off to a good start but let's offer the
best support for today's curriculum
that's what we're trying to do coding is
a central part of this change and I
think we've got the technology the
language and some of the start to
produced that and the question that
actually has been an interesting
question is a lot of people have said we
should make a Wolfram assessment that in
many countries in the world the math
assessment has become so degenerate that
we should actually build our own it
seems to me a horrifying prospect but
lots of people seem to want this and
anyway I'd be interested in people's
views on whether that's actually a good
idea or not a good idea I've always been
trying to separate our commercial
business from our education but people
seem to think that that maybe isn't the
right thing and they would value a
Wolfram assessment more than they value
some of their local exams in their own
country and employers would too so
thank you very much